i couldn't be a bigger fan of this man
um i've told him that to his face and
now i've told him that while he's
sitting on hold well i get set to
introduce the
uh only man other than bob hope to uh
host the oscars as many times as
he did he had me at hello when he was a
mime and spinal tap this is spinal tap
and uh the last time he directed a film
was the
great film 61 about mantle and maris 20
years ago and now he's
back helming this beautiful film that is
in a theater near you
starting tomorrow he directed he
co-wrote it he stars in the film with
the hilarious tiffany haddish the great
billy crystal here on the rich eisen
show how are you billy
i'm good good so nice to talk to you
rich thanks for having me
absolutely thank you for doing this i i
could go so many different directions
with you let's start with the yankees
did you see stanton homer again today
did you see that
already yeah he did their plan today
i just got up
so did stanton
yeah i know he's uh this is the best
he's ever played
right now for the year yeah i mean what
was the uh
the exit velocity
i can't get enough of that stuff too the
shift drives me nuts exit of a loss spin
rate
is something i did not grow up with yeah
you know the spin rate
um what do you what do you make of the
game today billy i guess i'll give you
the floor
on that baseball yeah what do you make i
always love baseball i mean at some of
the new rules
or i don't like the man on second in the
10th inning and right that kind of stuff
and i i you know the guys are bigger
stronger
you know when i was playing baseball i
was a second baseman i was the right
size
now you know i'm like a pinky ring to
these guys
and and uh so but it's still i i'd
prefer
to what's happening with the nba i have
to say what do you got what's what
what's with you in the end
i don't like the game anymore i just
don't like it it's all
you know three-pointers and that's it
and some of the games just feel like
all-star games
and um uh and you know the players are
coming
it'll get better for me uh and rooting
for the clip is hard
so how did you become a clipper fan
because i imagine
uh moving to los angeles that is a
conscious choice that's a very
that's a choice you have to make living
to law in los angeles that you choose
clippers over lakers how did that
happen for you i would i had laker seats
for a while
when i was here and um i mean when i
first got here
and then someone said to me um you ever
been to a clipper game and i
went basically you you was almost like
saying i don't i don't go downtown
and and i went and there was really
nobody there
a triple double meant there were three
couples in the club
[Laughter]
and so i i i liked the game i i just
there was something about
the sports arena which was so old and
and still had earthquake cracks in it
and they filled with foam if you
remember in some of the hallways it was
crazy
but there was something about the
underdog that i liked and
i just sort of stuck with it and every
time i thought i would leave
i'd go they just got a good draft pick
except it was all wakandi
you know so i just sort of stuck with it
and then
over time we got better and better we've
been really good for the last 10 years
so
um it's it's i know we just it was hard
to like say
that's it for us and and uh we're very
devoted to this team
so what about this year i mean i i
clearly you've established that you've
soured a bid on the game
nba but the the clippers are third
overall right now
and uh well i guess fourth right now uh
tied with the nuggets but
they're they're they're looking good
they're 22 over kawhi
obviously in uh george didn't perform in
the bubble the way that everyone
expected but this is a different year
what do you think yeah we're very deep
um we're still in a way getting to know
each other
you know it uh manning rondo and and
demarcus cousins who's who's look
better and better each game and um you
know but the players are different thing
i'd
i'd love to see uh terence man play more
and luke canard as they
work their uh rotations because they
just brought us so much life and brought
us uh
so much energy which the team really
needs so who's your favorite clipper of
all time
which one was that oh man um
what do you got from me uh the entirety
of your rooting
existence the one uh there's so many
there were so many actually there was
great idea
but uh elton brand was certainly great
for us
and chris you know chris who i for me is
the mvp the
of the league this year yes what he's
done um so i i think chris
and um and elton brand were just
sensational players for us
billy crystal here on the rich eisen
show before i get into
um your your film here today
um uh you know i was uh so moved it's
five years ago but i'll bring it up i
can't believe it's five years
but your your speech
your eulogy and memorializing muhammad
ali
five years ago was so remarkable it was
beautiful billy there's no other word
for it kind of like the movie that we're
going to talk about here today
because it is about mortality it is
about also
you know making the most of your time on
earth because you're here today and who
knows
about tomorrow your relationship with
muhammad ali started when
and were you up on that stage at any
point in time just
can't believe that you are in fact one
of the few chosen to
speak um about this this behemoth this
absolute legend on earth yeah
it was uh it was unbelievably moving in
an incredible
journey rich it started in uh right
after he beat george foreman
tonight that's 1974 and the late dick
shap
who was one of my closest friends um
this is the first time i met him
uh back in 74. he he was he was then the
editor of sport magazine
and ali was named the the man of the
year the sport magazine man the year so
they they were having this
local television special from the plaza
hotel
and he called my agent looking for
robert klein
who rob is a great comedian as you know
did a lot of funny sports stuff to do
like three four minutes
at the dinner and then robert was out of
town
so my agent said i've got this new kid
uh i'd not been on anything rich i'd not
done
anything i was a substitute teacher um
in the junior high that i went
to and so we said but i got this kid and
he does this really funny ali kho cell
thing it might be perfect for dixit
great
i don't even have to hear it have him at
the show uh friday around seven o'clock
the dinner starts at eight and he'll go
on around like eight thirty
so on so forth so i get this call that
i'm gonna be there and i'm gonna
sit on the dais um
the last day as i had been on was my bar
mitzvah
and when i i get there um it's
all of the men of the year in a
different sports
so archie griffin had won the heisman
he's there gina marchetti was
professional football
baltimore cults he's there on and on and
including
neil simon um who was you know
the greatest of all time um american
playwright in many ways
definitely comedy play ryan and it's and
it's all these amazing
people and and dick shows me where i'm
gonna sit and i go on three seats
from my hero because it wasn't
you know the boxing of course but
this was the guy who was the voice of my
generation
with the kennedy's gone and martin
luther king gone
this was the man who came to college
campuses this is the man who spoke about
vietnam
this is a man who defied the draft and
he spoke for us
and i'm three seats from him and i can't
believe that i'm
there and then i get up when a
dick introduces me which i said just
introduce me as
ali's closest and dearest friend because
nobody knew how the hell i was
because i didn't know and i'll go right
into the coast celibate i won't have to
explain anything
right and that'll relax me a little i
think funny it'll be funny that way so
he does it
ali's is staring at me as i walk behind
him i get to the podium i go right into
it
he goes crazy he calls me his little
brother
and that's how we were for 42 years for
that
so now he's gone i'm sitting there
in the coliseum and i'm sitting next to
president clinton
and i'm about to go up there and all i'm
thinking is
what if robert klein was in town
[Laughter]
right right i mean it's about it's about
faith it's about fate or destiny somehow
and
and it was a real friendship and i just
you know
to this day uh i i'm looking at i'm at
home looking at pictures of us together
when i was on tour with my broadway show
several sundays we were playing in
arizona
uh in a beautiful frank lloyd wright
theater there and it was ali's
uh 65th birthday so
i went to the house in the morning and
we had breakfast together and he said he
wanted to come to the show
so uh the show was at eight o'clock and
lonnie his amazing wife said
i'm concerned about him you know being a
distraction in the audience i said well
i'll i'll get a chair
and i'll put it in the wings and he'll
watch from the wings so we got like
this very comfortable um chair for him
it was almost like a throne and he
watched the show
from the wings and we when we went to
intermission
um i said to the audience before you go
i want to wish you a happy birthday to
who is now the greatest senior citizen
of all time
uh muhammad ali in a plot i said you
know i think you should applaud more
because
he's here and i brought him out from the
wings and and
the placement berserk it was it was
pretty amazing
pretty amazing life is amazing billy
crystal five-time emmy award winner tony
award winner
for um 700 sundays you just mentioned
and then this film
uh that's in theaters tomorrow that you
directed co-wrote
um and you star in the film with tiffany
haddish called here today
and you just mentioned you know what a
moving story about you know what you
said about muhammad ali and it was such
a beautiful speech
you were also and i thought about this
as i was watching your movie billy
you were also the mc for dick shaps
memorial i was there because as you know
i'm friendly with jeremy
or jeremy schapp espn um
you know as he always signs off and i
sat there
that day in that beautiful church uh
that landmark church
in new york and you you mentioned how
dick was 40 when you guys met
and i was you know in my early 30s
thinking that i had met
everybody in my life that i would
consider a great friend
by that point and i saw the fact that
you are now
emceeing a memorial for one of the
all-time greats paddy lupone
sang and martina navratilova spoke and
it it hit me so so hard that you know my
life is ahead of me
right like in terms of who you never
know who you're going to meet
and that's the sensibility in a way that
is in your film
right now that um about you playing
a writer um who is becoming
you know ill and and meeting tiffany
haddish
who becomes such an important member of
his life it
it really struck me it is a beautiful
film about mortality and about
humanity and i i just wanted to say that
to set you up about why you made this
film
billy i and i am i i'm glad you saw it
um
and and that it moved you um it's a it's
a movie about
the true meaning of friendship and love
um
and it's very funny and um
and it's it's uh it's about something
that's missing in our country
uh i believe which is empathy and
um it's about sacrifice about someone
giving up
something important to them to help
somebody else who's in need
and um i wanted to do a you know i
started writing it with my dear friend
allen zweibell who was an original snl
writer we've known each other
for 40 almost 50 years and um
i saw him on the letterman show and he
described this
this charity auction lunch that he went
through
which was just a disaster which is
true in the movie that's what that's
what set me off he was on letterman
talking about it
he's having lunch with this woman she
taught she says she doesn't
really like humor and and she
said well i'm just curious how much did
you pay for the auction he said 22
dollars
and and then she has a reaction to the
seafood salad she blows up
he has to get an ambulance she has no
insurance he's at the
the hospital they give him a bill for
twenty three hundred dollars and he has
to give her an epipen shot to save her
life
so this is a luncheon from hell so i'm
watching letterman i started writing
i i wrote them out this is a great way
to start something
i don't know who these people are of
course but what a great way to
start the relationship uh let's see
where we go
and that's that's that was the jumping
off point and then
i was dealing with a relative it was
really my last
relative standing and she was a novelist
and had written seven books and
a very brilliant woman and she started
to lose her vocabulary
as she said i'm losing my words and it
was so moving to me and we took care of
her right
you know up until um we couldn't anymore
and um i thought if we could roll that
in
to this character then what was thought
so it starts off as a broad comedy
becomes something much more important
then we might really have something and
then we just started taking off from
there and
developing the characters and over two
year period we had a script that we
liked
got it to tiffany um she signed on
immediately
i met her i had i had only seen her
on snl hosting which she was fantastic
and i said look at this this is meant to
be um
she's so funny she's so charming she
sings she does all the things that
the character emma page has to do in the
film
and um and that was it and um i'm really
blessed to have worked with her
and that she's she's um was so willing
to stretch rich you know she's a five
tool player
she's a five she it's a five top
no she does it all and combine that and
use
that um all those different talents and
really
you know even stretch her in in ways
that she hadn't done in films and she
was so
uh willing to to grow and and and
develop herself you know and and she's
beautiful in the movie
and uh again the movie the beautiful is
a great way to describe it and it's
available
um in theaters nationwide starting
tomorrow um
it's called here today so can i tell you
one last little story
in that beautiful church saint john's uh
what dicks memorial was yes
that's where howard cosell's funeral was
no kidding
yeah so it's i think it holds fifteen
hundred people
and they were out on the streets with
loudspeakers up and i'm sitting
next to ali and it's a it's a closed
casket
okay flowers on top everything and the
speech after speech
and ali taps me on my arm
and whispers to me in my ear he says
this
do you think he's wearing his hairpiece
[Laughter]
how does one respond i was like this was
one of those like you know who passed
cast and
you know in church or synagogue somebody
farted and
you can't hold your laughter you know so
i'm holding it in and i and i go
i don't think so and he goes so how will
god recognize him
so i said once he opens his mouth he'll
know who he is
it was hilarious absolutely hilarious
oh cosell is part of the reason why i'm
in this business
uh i grew up watching him on monday
night football seeing his
cameos on the odd couple you know
seriously like growing up in new york
city
listening to him marv albert's the other
another reason why
um but kosel you just don't
you know i mean how many lawyers turned
broadcasters are we ever going to see
ever again in in our in our lifetime
so i assume did he did he like your your
imitation or
oh yeah oh very much so very much so and
then i started you know
you play around with them you know one
was bigger it was you know sort of
predictable
the kind of imitation of him but then i
started doing him
uh like ordering room service in a
in a hotel on the phone i'm much funnier
it would be like hello room service i
would go sell room 707
listen i'd like some eggs over easy and
then an english muffin well done place
not like yesterday
just kidding
oh rich he was bigger than life though
you know
wasn't he i mean one year
in the tv guide poll he was most
most admired and most hated in the same
poll oh yeah
so that's you know that's that's that's
where you want to be for somebody like
that
i can't get enough of those stories al
michaels has a million of them as i'm
sure you know
uh about uh cosell and you know it kind
of kills me that we're
in a day and age where some of us might
have to actually explain to others who
he was and what he meant
uh oh yeah but um a giant
an absolute giant billy i could take up
your entire day i really could because
we didn't even hit
uh anything from your filmography but
let's let's
do this again whenever you wish i'd love
to have you back billy all right rich
good to see you i hope to see you at a
game sometimes it means that we're
getting back to normal
i would look forward to it maybe at
playoffs maybe the players i hope so
what do you think what's your choice
i i don't know i think you you might be
right deep down
this could be chris paul's year i don't
know i know they got spanked last night
but that's just recency bias
um don't you think he's the mvp i think
you know
you've got a joke has been unbelievable
i mean i watch it he did stuff
last night that i just to the next i
just couldn't believe and
but they don't have anybody with any
kind of bulk to guard him because you
know he's a
he's a truck this guy you've been so
talented there's doc's
new spot too there's doc's new spot and
and joel embiid has been
phenomenal i mean just off the charts
phenomenal
so you never know steph curry has been
maybe the best he's ever been
it's a great conversation though but
paul has been incredible
he has been yeah so what a great guy i
look forward to uh seeing how it will
play out billy thanks for the call
congrats on your time you bet that's uh
billy crystal the director co-writer and
star
of here today which you can see in
theaters near you
starting tomorrow hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here